the water I don't know how
the guy in the coast god you know we all
get scared out there I'm not afraid of
the water
this guy's midnight that's all you can't
see what's underneath just more water
station chatham you copy
I repeat conditions Angeles got an
18-foot fracture not home how do you
want us to proceed over
you know the same that's gonna be the
biggest storm that ever hit the East
Coast it's gonna be hurricane strength
in a no come biz why how are you wait so
long before you suggested going out on
the date I just didn't know if you'd be
attracted to me
you're exactly how I pictured you yeah
what's this on a radio ship wreck it up
she's a t2 tanker split right in half we
got maybe two three hours and then we
sink chief pick yourself a crew you
assist that ship here it's why I signed
up yes now's my chance
man and I don't know what he's doing his
sinning you want to die the Coast Guard
they say you gotta go out they don't say
you gotta come back in dust it Bernie go
out on a rescue I'm worried about this
isn't one any other girl still so no
one's getting over the bar in this
weather it's a suicide mission
please tell me we're taking that boat to
a bigger boat
you don't know what it's like out there
dawn please call him back in you can't
be in here miss
I can get you know we're supposed to get
married you're gonna come in here scare
every time he got in the water please
call them back not giving up on him not
on my watch
he's got his orders get her out of here
cuz sending about to die brace yourself